uh children
women and men the young and the old
are living in terror
they're suffering in ukraine and in so
many different parts of the world
grieving about what they lost yesterday
holding their breath about what they
could lose today
and what tomorrow can bring
at a time like this the law cannot be a
spectator
the law cannot recline in comfort in the
hague or anywhere else for that matter
when it's meant to protect and
uphold certain principles that are
essential for humanity
just like a climate strategy and a covet
strategy
we need an accountability strategy
a strategy driven by the universal
belief that all of us
all of us are protected by law
ensuring that all roads
lead to justice
now
and in the future ukraine calls on the
establishment of a special tribunal
which would have a specific jurisdiction
over the crime of aggression against
ukraine
we have heard a number of reservations
since the idea first floated in the
early march
most of them expressed concern that this
effort could replace existing
international courts and tribunals thus
weakening them
i want to clearly reiterate
we do not have any such intention and
this will not be the outcome of our
effort
in fact we have always been working
closely with all international courts
and tribunals and in particular the icc
we have to fill the vacuum
and and the icc here doesn't have the
jurisdiction
so i can imagine that that you know we
do look into
coming up with such a tribunal
as a netherlands we will take an open
look into this it will probably not be
easy
it's there is merit in doing that with
as many friends as possible from the
international community
but we will seek to support ukraine
where we can
we are setting up a collaboration
initiative allowing us to fight impunity
better
together
also in the future
because our joint voices must not be a
one-off access exercise
our combined efforts must and will not
stop here today
we need to translate our shared and
strong conviction for justice into a
unified answer
against impunity there will be a
declaration in due course that 45 states
have signed up to
which is a promise to show the stamina
moving forward
but if we are to
resist the failings of the past to have
this stampede that is some side
sometimes seen of
different actors
running to crime scenes
we need to be coordinated we need to
have dialogue we need to have
communication and the dialogue
group that is going to be established in
due course is an important means